hello and welcome to our channel today
we're going to talk about garbaneri of
the iron fortress the world is in the
midst of the industrial revolution when
horrific creatures emerge from a
mysterious virus ripping through the
flesh of humans to save their
never-ending appetite the only way to
kill these beings known as garbane is by
destroying their steel-coated hearts
however if bitten by one of these
monsters the victim is doomed to a fate
far worse than death mankind has created
a massive wall to protect themselves
from the endless hordes of garbane the
only way into these giant fortresses is
via heavily armoured trains on the
island country of hinomoto an armored
train is attacked by several garbane at
the train's destination the mce comma a
steam smith is working on a powerful
piercing gun to kill the garbane when
the train arrives at the station igor
must steal some garbani body parts for
his experiment he's detained for
insubordination later another train
arrives at the station the defensive
drawbridge is lowered but the train is
taken over by the garbane who crash it
into the wall allowing them to attack
the station ikoma flees to his home
lures garbani into the house and kills
it with his bolt gun but is bitten in
the process and begins to transform into
a carbane using several painful and
potentially fatal techniques ikomas
stops his blood flow from carrying the
virus to his brain he successfully does
so reverting to his human form and
passing out meanwhile a girl named mummy
kills a carbine using a blade which
forms the base of her shoe
igorma discovering that he stopped the
garbane virus from infecting him tells
his fellow steamsmith takumi of his
success meanwhile the rest of the
survivors seek an opportunity to escape
into the armored trade but they get
surrounded by karbani mummy arrives
dressed in battlegear and offers to
clear the way she leaps into the midst
of the garbane and leads them away
killing several in the process the
remaining citizens then rushed to board
the train meanwhile igorma and takumi
attempt to board the train with his gun
moon made to take something different
about egoma and vouchers for him so he
can board the train ayame the station
owner's daughter uses the special key to
start the train's engine gurusu ayame's
personal bodyguard tells mumey to defend
the train's rear but she refuses and
falls asleep while fending off a garbane
ikoma's infected heart is exposed he
gets shot by gurusu and falls off the
train however the train is stopped by a
malfunction of the drawbridge and the
passengers witness ikonwa killing the
garbane lecturing the passengers for
their distrust igor manually releases
the drawbridge allowing the train to
leave despite the people's objections
nakumi and mumei get ikoma back on the
train before kurusu can kill him mummy
intervenes and reveals that she and
ikoma are carbonari beings within
existence between humans and gabbani
after mumei reveals her identity as a
carbonari ayame stops gurusu from
killing the carbonari and reminds
everyone that they were rescued by ikoma
and mume the train is headed for the
gong gogango greatest stronghold and
mummy insists on staying on board
however the passengers are filled with
alarm and distrust because of a lack of
food water and whether they'll be
admitted into gongokaku because of the
presence of the carbonaria accompanying
them mummy reveals that she has a
mission and needs help from ikoma
because she gets exhausted after
fighting she begins training igama
personally in preparation for future
garbane attacks the train stops for
water and repairs and the passengers
take the opportunity to pray for those
who died at the station ikoma tells
mummy that he has vowed to avenge his
sister's death at the hands of the
garbane while holding a green stone tied
to his palm which seems to have some
effect on the garbane mummy reveals that
garbaneri can only survive by drinking
human blood as people start panicking a
pregnant woman becomes a garbane and
mummy kills her meanwhile ayami attacks
ikoma but he tells her about his vow to
kill garbane appeasing the passengers
fears of the carbonari however he
becomes insane from his own need of
blood and attacks her
gurusu rescues ayame just as the garbane
appear in the woods surrounding the
train and everyone gets back on board
still fearful of the garbaneri the six
chiefs ask ayami to hand over the
train's master key to her dismay one of
the chiefs reroutes the train for the
mountains to provide a short route to
gongokaku in spite of the increased
danger posed by the garbane on the
exposed mountain path then they forced
dakumi and a girl to go to the train's
last wagon where mumei and ikoma are and
attach the car however the garbane
including wazatori a gabane that's
learned combat techniques and is thus
much more dangerous ambushed the train
and kills some of the passengers ayami
gurusu and the warriors hold off the
garbane while the surviving passengers
escaped to the train's front using his
sword wielding skills gurusu fights the
remaining carbane inside the train at
close quarters simultaneously mume igoma
and their allies escape from their car
and fight the garbane but mermaid falls
asleep from exhaustion gurusu fights the
wazatori but is injured in the process
with ikoma in need of fresh blood ayami
slashes her arm and replenishes him with
her blood after ikoma kills the wazatori
they all celebrate their victory ayami
regains the master key and declares that
she'll allow the carbonari to stay on
board the train offering her blood to
help sustain them igorma's friends and a
number of others including gurusu join
her
igoma helps the warriors develop weapons
to kill the garbani the trade arrives to
another station which was attacked by
garbane who still remain with him the
train passengers rescues some human
survivors who talk of a black fog before
the attack mume meets enoku a crippled
fighter still loyal to her brother the
young master he warns that the shogunate
is acting suspiciously by stockpiling
weapons that aren't for killing garbane
and advises her to complete her mission
since the debris blocked the tracks the
train committee decided to use a crane
to remove it ikomar suggests a cautious
route to the crane but mummy
unexpectedly insists on a head-on clash
with the garbane while ecomart leads a
group of engineers to start the crane
mummy attacks the nest of garbanese
single-handedly estimating that she has
90 seconds of energy left she defeats
them but before the working party can
start the crane even more garbane appear
the crew retreat and ikomas starts to
lift the debris with the crane while
mume uses her remaining energy to fight
the horde of garbane she's then attacked
by a wazatori and ikomar goes to her aid
before he completely removes the debris
at that moment a giant shadowy figure
heads towards the train
the black fog is revealed to be a colony
of garbane fused into one giant beast
unable to leave the train retreats to
the station workshop and they seal the
door the committee discussed their
options of whether to leave or stay
ikomar finds mumei trapped under rubble
and tries to release her unable to free
her he leads the garbani away from her
and kills as many as he can later gurusu
and some others rescue mummy via a
tunnel she runs to find ikoma who is
badly wounded and they all return to the
train together while the black fog beast
is distracted feeding on the bodies of
the dead garbhane ecomart removes the
wreckage from the tracks mummy suggests
a plan to kill the beast using everyone
working together the train leaves the
workshop with the beast in pursuit at
the last possible moment they shoot the
beast with the train's cannon and moonme
kills the woman controlling it who much
to her surprise was a carbonari like her
with the beast defeated the train leaves
the station the train arrives at another
station which is occupied by humans
they're only allowed to stay for a
couple of days they're offered food and
other provisions in exchange for the jet
bullets technology invented by ikoma
mumei reveals to ikoma that her name was
hozumi before she became a carbonari and
he promises that he'll make her human
again the following day an elite team
arrives at hans garbane led by bieber
who mummy calls her brother however
ikomar is suspicious of bibar's past and
whether he's really a hero or something
else
bibar's introduced to ayami later the
garbane attacked the station and biba
takes his hunt to squad and destroys
them all he also kills enoku who he
accuses of betrayal he then offers to
accompany ayame's train to gongogaku and
she accepts ikoma suspects that mumei's
brother turned her into a carbonari and
gave the name mummy for his own purposes
bieber asks mumey to take the train's
master key from ayame but she's tricked
and given the wrong key ikomar discovers
that biba is transporting garbane on his
train but biba uses moomai to prevent
him from entering the carriage iguoma is
convinced that mummai's brother is not a
hero
biba's trade is refused entry by the
shogun samurai to iwato station the last
before kongokaku ayame decides to park
company with the hunters and asks ikoma
to get mume lord maeda leader of the
fortress agrees to a meeting with biba
on the condition that only women and
children accompany him during the
meeting mummy leaves saying that she
needs to go to the toilet and lowers the
station's drawbridge to let bibar's
garbane into the station biba then kills
lord maida when mume sees the garbani
attack on the station she's horrified by
the consequences of her actions
meanwhile biba's men take ayami hostage
and kill the shogun samurai for what
biba says is retribution for the show
grenade's cowardice for the past 10
years he believes that only the strong
should survive biba injects his
carbonary named hirobi with a serum so
that she can become the heart of another
black fog beast gathering all the
garbane into a single colony called nue
she's getting shot but all in vain the
nue destroys the great gate as the virus
gets into her head the noise defeated
but hirobi survives and continues to
fight when she reaches biba he kills her
since she served her purpose in the
aftermath biba and his men controlled a
devastated iwato station muammad then
realizes that everything bibar had told
her was a lie biba and his troops are
now in control of ayami's train and its
passengers using their blood to feed
this garbani biba offers a deal to ayame
that if she can open the gates to
gongukaku and arrange a meeting with his
father he will guarantee the safety of
her people he tells at the time when his
father sent him with 400 000 troops to
kyushu to fight the garbane but when
replacement supplies failed to arrive
they were overrun and wiped out for
which he blames his father meanwhile
ikomar hatches a daring plan with some
of the passengers to retake control of
the train biba offers muammar a chance
to join his troops but she refuses and
is forced to take captive vaccine and
sedated ikomar's group starts their
attack to take control of the train but
biba had anticipated a counter-attack
and confronts ikoma killing takumi who
sacrifices himself to save ikuma biba
then calls on mummy to kill egoma she
obeys his orders due to bibar's captive
vaccine stabbing ikoma who falls from
the train into the coast far below
gurusu who went missing in the previous
attack finds ikomas still alive washed
up on the shore meanwhile biba injects
mummy with the same liquid that he used
on hirobi to turn it into a nue the
train arrives at gongogaku and announces
that they've captured the men who
destroyed iwato station so they're
allowed entry ayami pretends to have
bibar prisoner because a crew are being
held hostage and they're taken to meet
the shogun biba tricks the shogun into
holding a sword tainted with the garbane
virus which turns him into a garbane
biba then kills him and announces to
everyone that garvane are among them
which creates a panic and people start
to kill each other out fear the warriors
of bibar take the train into the city
and release the garbane while ayame
escapes with the help of her uncle
gurusu has one of bibar scientists
prisoner with knowledge about the
carbane virus he says the mumei can be
saved once she becomes a new way by
injecting white plasma into her heart
ikoma insists on being injected by black
plasma to give him additional strength
although it will accelerate the garbanet
virus and shorten his life mummy begins
her transformation into a new way to
fulfill bibar's dream of destruction
ikoma and kurusu enter kongokaku drawing
the garbani towards them ayame appeals
to the humans to stop attacking each
other in fear and entreats them to leave
gongokaku with her people in the train
meanwhile ikoma is able to reach mumei
with gurusu's help moomate seems to be
unaware of what she's become recalling
memories from the past and imagining
herself surrounded by butterflies
as ikoma is getting closer to her
suddenly he's intercepted by biba who's
revealed as a carbonari during the fight
biba stabs ikomar with his sword but
this doesn't kill him and as he's about
to try again ikomar recovers and blasts
him with his bulk gun mummy appears to
understand that ekomart is near and she
allows him to inject her with the white
serum destroying the new way and
returning her to a previous form bibar
who's still alive approaches ikoma to
fight him but mummy stops him and stabs
him with her sword
ayami and her people leave the
smoldering city of gongokaku in the
train with gurusu mummy and an injured
ikoma on board ikomas starts to recover
thanks to a serum secretly given by biba
and the effects of the black serum seem
to diminish as an afterthought moomey
hands him back his green stone
so this is it for today's video if you
like the video give it a huge thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel for more
videos farewell till next time